hey everyone I'm Tessa and this is
episode two of IBM cloud now our
bi-weekly web series bring you the
latest and greatest announcements from
IBM cloud today we're covering what's
new with IBM edge application manager
the latest coupe version for IBM cloud
kubernetes service and how travel pink
is using IBM cloud to innovate driving
with connected cars to start we're
excited to announce that IBM edge
application manager version 4.0 is now
available edge application manager it's
a solution that is built on an
open-source platform and runs on RedHat
OpenShift
there are a whole bunch of new features
and enhancements in the 4.0 release but
these are our top five first this
release supports the installation of the
edge management hub on RedHat open shift
container platform version 4.2 for the
hub cluster this provides you with
autonomous management features that help
you deploy workloads at a massive scale
second there's improved scalability for
edge devices up to ten thousand edge
devices per edge application manager hub
third this release provides a simplified
developer experience with openshift
platform and supports an edge native
programming model fourth you'll enjoy an
enhanced user experience with the edge
UI and fifth this release provides
faster onboarding of edge devices via
bulk installation and registration of
the agent for a full rundown of
everything you'll get with a 4.0 release
hit the link in the description below
next up kubernetes version one point 17
point 2 is now available in IBM cloud
community service this release includes
a whopping 22 enhancements including the
GA of cloud provider labels and a beta
release for volume snapshot and CSI
migration IBM cloud kubernetes service
now supports the latest three versions
of kubernetes 1.15 one point one six and
one point one seven there's a full
rundown of all the new features and
updates in the link below and finally I
wanted to quickly shine the spotlight
and a cool partnership that's going on
between travel ping and IBM cloud
connected cars with IOT devices are
becoming more and more prevalent but
these vehicles often experience latency
issues that can affect safety insights
travel being explored the problem and
felt that it had to get the network
closer to the connected devices so with
help from IBM cloud the company used a
self developed kubernetes cluster to
create a scalable cloud native
Paquette Gateway solution that transmits
the data to the vehicles result was that
travel paying an IBM cloud solution
reduced IOT latency by more than 95
percent for real-time vehicle safety
data insights
it saved resources by providing scalable
services on commodity hardware and it
kept data in the country by transporting
the payloads to where the vehicles are
very cool stuff we've got a link below
that gives you the whole story behind
this innovative partnership thanks for
joining me for this episode of IBM cloud
now if you want to learn more about any
of the topics discussed today check out
the links in the description and don't
forget to subscribe to our Channel and
stay up-to-date on what's going on in
the cloud now